we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is a bernie voter who so far
is pleased with joe biden take a listen
david i was a big bernie supporter and
i wasn't naive enough to think that uh
voting for somebody else would benefit
the democrats or my beliefs as a
progressive
so i voted for biden and voting for
biden right now and like you said in the
first six or seven days he
actually already impressed me i
understand it's only executive orders
and nothing's been
brought to the senate or the house yet
but
i actually feel more optimistic than i
originally did and i'm really excited
about it and thanks david
and by the way this is steer from
wisconsin and
his wife jenny thinks your shirt is
still too busy i like the yellow one
remind me of star trek a little bit
all right thanks dude appreciate
everything was that my sweater is
filthy busy i've never heard that i
don't know what the kids these days are
talking about but i've never heard that
before uh
i think that that's very interesting to
hear and i've heard from a bunch of
bernie supporters uh who are saying
so far i mean for the first week of joe
biden he's really actually done
quite a few things including things like
freezing saudi arms deal
that i think very few people expected
him to do
certainly within the first week so we
will continue tracking and holding joe
biden accountable but
much to be pleased about in the first
seven or eight days
we have much to talk about on today's
bonus show including this is crazy
china is deploying an anal swab for
covid testing
why why is this necessary we will talk
about the medical elements involved
there
also the pence's mike and karen are
apparently homeless in couchsurfing
right now
what is going on with that and more on
the gamestop
short squeeze on today's bonus show
sign up at jointpakman.com i'll see you
there